hey rejects its Greg here just got back
from a trip from San Diego when I go and
weekend getaway trips I delete all apps
off my phone I don't bring my camera
with me like to actually unplug from the
internet for a good amount of time just
stay away just focus on my experience on
the people I'm with in the trip uh-huh
but now that I'm back The Mummy trailer
was released recently I'm already very
skeptical of this film honestly I'm a
huge Tom Cruise fan I've been a major
like the way I've been passionate about
my love for Mel Gibson despite his
hardship is the same way I've been
passionate about my love for Tom
Cruise's work when he was like jumping
on couches and talking all about
Scientology all the time and all that
stuff when I wrote was a tin on it but I
saw Jack Reacher never go back I thought
that was just garbage and it was the
first time in a very long time where Tom
Cruise himself let me down I just kind
of died I just sorry for me to imagine
the mummy film working with Tom Cruise I
don't know why I'm having the hardest
time letting it click something keeps
time is it gonna feel more like a Tom
Cruise film instead of a mummy film but
let's add an ally okay just wipe away
all preconceived notions just watched
Universal meaning no monetization on
this video it's like talk for as long as
I want
rogue nation interesting oh no whoa
but the funny
[Music]
hyrum
that is scream then must have been like
some actors oh whoa
my stills buffers ever welcome to a new
world of guns
and monsters
[Music]
whoa
[Music]
please meet princess dominant she will
claim that she has been tonight
[Music]
confused and intrigued at the same time
that was just the first trailer for what
I'm assuming is a 2 plus hour film
well first off I think I'm right that
fell way more like a Tom Cruise action
flick as opposed to The Mummy is back
like this is supposed to be the relaunch
of like the Universal Monsters coming to
life again and it has like elements of
Mission Impossible and an edge of
tomorrow gnashed in there I don't know
why Tom Cruise a scream sounded like
that I heard from John Bailey that
sometimes to do like dubbing over in
trailers they'll have actors of like
footage is not complete or something
they'll hire voice actors to fill in
like lines of dialogue and I'm just like
that doesn't sound like Tom Cruise
screaming it sound like a weird scream
in that trailer
I'm definitely not disinterested it
looks it looks a little bit confusing on
what is going on here like I thought it
would be something more simple in terms
of like Tom Cruise human being and they
pick up the mummy thing and all this
[ __ ] starts going wrong they have this
really intense sequence where they make
it apparent that Tom Cruise's character
should be dead and he's not dead so I'm
like his Tom Cruise The Mummy and some
way like why is he still alive from that
incident like this he have superpowers
himself - there's some really cool shots
they have in here - I like this shower
he like goes inside of the bus when the
bus is flipped over I felt like we had
two different plots going on here like
there was the first half of the trailer
was dedicated to Tom Cruise's character
crashing inside of that plane and then
he comes back to life and then the last
half is like dedicated to this new kind
of villainous mummy character and I'm
not saying like it won't make sense when
the film comes together I'm just a
little bit confused as to what to really
look forward to in this movie one thing
I am looking forward to regardless like
even though I don't think this is gonna
be any of their best work is seeing
Russell Crowe and
Kruse acting together I mean I'm sure
that how like maybe one or two scenes
together but I love both of those actors
and I love like what my favorite actors
get to have a scene together so that's
something I'm really looking forward to
seeing and I'm okay with the fact that
they're making this mummy a modern day
film here's my concern though like I
said before like I if you look back on
any of the mummy films they feel like
films about the mummy this feels like a
Tom Cruise action summer film still that
happens to have the mummy and the title
how do I put this you know how like the
movie predator you think of the movie
predator predator is about you know the
the predator in the jungle killing these
people and yeah Schwarzenegger is a star
so it's technically a Schwarzenegger
film just like how this is technically a
Tom Cruise film but in the same way how
predator is still about the predator and
it feels much more than just a
Schwarzenegger movie it's a predator
movie that happens to star Arnold
Schwarzenegger and to me this doesn't
feel that way this to me like the way
it's being promoted currently feels like
a Tom Cruise movie that has stuff about
a mummy in it not the mummy movie that
happens to star Tom Cruise I'm not sure
if I'm making much sense on this but if
it's kind of just where I'm a little
conflicted on it doesn't mean it's gonna
be a bad movie I just I really like the
old-school mommy honestly and I love the
first two Brendan Fraser ones as well
I'm hoping this is good I'm hoping and I
feel like most of the time Tom Cruise
kills it for me if that's his actual
stream I'm a little bit concerned and at
the same time - I've seen some trailers
for some Tom Cruise films that ended up
like Tom Cruise films that I thought
like mouths are not good trailers bye
love them like I remember edge it's
tomorrow I think is an amazing amazing
film but I remember being a little let
down by some of the trailers for it and
I feel like you know what when it comes
to movies these days you can't ever
really trust a trailer even if a trailer
is great or if a trailer is horrible
sometimes you just are totally wrong
when you actually watch the movie I'm
go watch this movie regardless even if I
see another that makes me feel like this
looks like [ __ ] I'm still gonna tune in
for it so yeah what do you guys think of
it if you're new to the channel you can
subscribe today become accepted cuz
you're initially a reject I said the
little outro phase drunk and shout out
to sleep sleep is good sleep is usually
a necessity after you get off the road
after many hours held in the bathroom
for a very long time and just had a lot
of awkwardness on the way home
shout out to sleep